normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government this
was uh big news that broke after the
debate uh Tim Cass with the scoop Ron
McDaniel overheard trashing VI ramaswami
in debate audience saying he won't get a
sent from us he's an a-hole total a-hole
McDaniel said a source who was sitting
near McDaniel told timcast news that she
was uh she was not attempting to keep
her voice lowered apparently tons of
people heard this and she called him an
a-hole and declared the party would not
be giving him a scent he's an a-hole
total a-hole he's desperate because he's
doing bad in the polls he won't be
getting a scent from us she was in
complete meltdown over V the V The
Source said this was in the middle of
the audience with an earshot of at least
50 people so apparently after it after
the debate V apparently was having like
was talking to her at the edge of the
stage now we have this from the New York
Post Ron McDaniel claps back at vas
Swami he's at 4% and needs a headline
this is in line with exactly what uh the
timcast news source said that she was
saying in the audience and she went on
to say something like uh let me see if
they have it in this story because VI
like struck back here here we go she
says I know that VI is kind of newer to
the party he voted for Obama so he may
not know that ramaswami claimed he did
not vote in any presidential election
between 08 and 2016 voting for
libertarian Michael badner in 04 and
former president Trump in 2020 so she's
just Lo losing it and outright lying now
about v i I got to tell you I I think I
know what what Ron McDaniel and the GOP
establishment is doing what do we keep
hearing from D santis people oh it's
Trump's fault that we're losing all
these elections it's Trump's fault oh
the Trump candidates are losing they are
intentionally sabotaging Republicans and
we hear it
non-stop we just had jusan talking about
how he gets he gets uh basically cut off
and they they sabotage him they're doing
it so they can say see Trump's bad for
the party give us back the power let us
be in control and shut your mouths I saw
it firsthand how Antiquated the GOP is
at the debate in California you know
these the Nikki Haley the disantis they
all walk off the stage no one really
cares when they walk into the Press Room
you know they get the the Hannity
treatment and they go away KY Lake and
vake were the people that people the
real press swarmed like you know and
that was they were the center of
attention and Nome which is a issue
because like Hannity loved being around
Newsome so much which is bizarre but
like everyone else no one cared you know
Chris chrisy doesn't even go to the The
Press Room you know literally no one
cares Ron is like the Kathleen Kennedy
for the GOP like she just keeps losing
for us and if we look at how if I get
this wrong correct me but even during
the 2022 midterms we saw that McCarthy
was not supporting America First
candidates right we saw fing yes we saw
funding going actually against those
candidates and this is the G playing for
a long time because you have that comes
in that is anti-establishment you know
it's the only reason I voted for Trump
in 2020 I didn't vote in 2016 for didn't
vote at all but you see these things
happen you're like man maybe there
actually is a voice pushing forward we
actually can have meaningful change yeah
it makes me wonder I mean if her smear
to him is that he voted for Obama you
know I believe him I believe he didn't
but if if he did and now he's running
for president that's a huge change and I
think it would be interesting to talk to
someone and say how did you come from
either not voting or voting for Obama to
wanting to really be a part of a very
serious America first movement it's sort
of a Mis opportunity on her part where
she's saying you're threatening my power
and she can't see what what's actually
good for the party they're elitist
they're upholding the uni party and they
hate Outsiders like Trump car lake so
you know well and like she's saying he's
not going to get a sent from us I mean f
has a lot of money I'm sure he doesn't
want to spend it all in his campaign I'm
sure donors are good and things like
that but like he doesn't actually need
it and exactly and this is how you get
get independence within the party the V
does not need to bend the knee to the
corporate lobbying interests and that's
why he's able to say things that has
that has us all riled up and all excited
cuz he's like I don't need your money
screw off you suck and then they're like
well I'm not going to give you any money
he's like I got more money than you do
exactly I have a deep concern for these
people let's let's just say Trump's not
in office you know we're with someone
who doesn't have Trump money or vake
money do you think they're going to come
after them any less than the way they
came after these two people who can
actually afford their court fees no it's
going to be the same tactics being
forward we are we are in this now they
will attack anyone who comes in anyone
and make the taxpayers pay for it yes
people need to understand R McDaniel
likes the Democrats more than she likes
VI more than she likes you she will
absolutely shake the hand and smile uh
uh you know shake the hand of like Gavin
news and smile and everything while
calling Vian a-hole the the the
establishment Republican party sabotaged
Republicans helping Democrats win
because they did not want to lose power
in the party establishment yes exactly
which is the opposite of America first
but you know what man look Patrick B
David put out a poll and said who do you
think you know one or whatever and V 80
90% I think it was like 91 92% and then
you look at the like the New York Times
and everything and they're like oh he
did the worst the machine hates VI but
you know what VI is effectively the
right leaning leader of the millennial
generation and I don't think I don't see
any other way to phrase this he is
running for president he is 38 years old
imagine where he's going to be in 10 or
15 years he is going to be one of the
most prominent personalities speaking to
the more uh Centrist to conservative uh
factions within the millennial
generation and and to a great extent gen
Z but when we hear the things that he's
saying it very much resonates with many
of us you know in it's like a wide an
range maybe you can even say the key
demo because Nikki Haley's not talking
to anybody who's she talking to Rhonda
Sanders a little bit but he's still
trying to capture that old neocon energy
MH the's the only one who it seems like
is saying you'll see me in four years
right the also is the only one who
really speaks like a human being on that
stage you know it sounds like he's done
podcasts like you know RFK as well uh
Tucker obviously these people can talk
with depth for a long amount of time and
not just exem charismatic and you you
can't you can't manufacture that I mean
that's just the way it is I think one of
the best parts about V is that he is so
young and full of energy I mean I just
fundamentally believe that he is capable
of doing a lot and that's good for the
party the fact that they will not
Embrace him number one tells us that
he's probably good I mean I if if Ron
mcdal doesn't like them that is a reason
to maybe research them and be interested
a little bit more uh but he's going to
last like if you know he doesn't get
what he wants out of this election I'm
sure he will do something else and
that's what I think young Republicans or
young conservative leaning people even
Independents need to see that it's not
just fall in line or and stop or or stop
it's it's keep going no matter what
we're taking it over I do think gen Z
will probably wake up in the next 5 to
10 years because they're still very
young you know I don't blame them for
being young they're just young but as
they continue to live life and they
don't have an opportunity to buy a home
they're paying 800 bucks for for buying
a car because interest rates are also
high on those as well they're going to
realize what we're voting for is not
working they will see the effects of
their decisions but it's going to take
some time and will be there four years
from now to say hey are we ready now but
I've said this so many times I don't
think people are ready yet I think there
will have to be a measure of suffering
that that will have to continue yep and
it's sad however uh I I agree with you I
will say the only thing that matters to
me is that we win culturally because for
for too long people on the right
conservatives have thought we got to win
the votes we got to win the votes and
Democrats have been saying get them when
they're kids it's like the cigarette
companies yo get them while they're
young get them to smoke early and so
this is the general idea my concern
right now I look to what the daily wire
is doing with bent key and I'm like
that's huge that's huge give give
families an opportunity to give their
kids something that's not W garbage and
then what I'm you know what we're
talking about doing is we put out a
documentary uh INF fringed with laurren
s we put out game of money with uh uh
Ben Stewart we're making way more and
the goal there is what are we going to
do are we going to are we going to take
the money that we make from running this
like doing this show and and doing these
other shows and then try and campaign to
win elections that to me is NS yeah but
we put these documentaries we keep
pushing them and we create a library of
entertaining content we make music we're
working on the skate show the boonies we
got pro skateboarders coming down we
want to own this space so uh shout out
to Richie Jackson pro skateboarder he
took a picture oh man I love this I wake
up in the morning I'm sitting on a
toilet and I'm scrolling through
Instagram cuz that's what we do and I
see Shredder news it's a skateboarding
news outlet and sure enough there's the
picture that Richie posted the other day
with Lauren Southern pro skateboarder
taking a picture with Lauren Southern
holding fake guns their toys and it's a
with the infringed logo and I think he
just did it because I thought it was
funny and it created a quote unquote
backlash in the skate culture and I'm
like this means that these teenagers
they're uh uh they're they're like
Richie's Richie's an amazing dude and
he's he's like a super Superstar you
know he's he's a very unque birthday too
by the way birthday Y and uh there are
people go up to him and they're like
dude you're my favorite skater they're
so excited to meet him and they see that
he's fearless and he's and he's willing
to support things that he agrees with
he's not scared of what these activists
say to him that's what we want to build
and so I can look to the vacon I can
cheer him on I can look to all the
voting stuff but I'm like let me let me
tell you exactly what our plan is and
I'll simplify it in this way a story
some of you may have heard me me say or
a general idea pro athlete says I'm too
scared to speak up about males competing
against females because I'll lose my
sponsors then I say okay our company
makes enough money to sponsor you we'll
sponsor you will you speak up now and
they'll go oh okay great then the other
company will say hey if you you post
those Instagram things arguing about
politics we're going to drop you as a
sponsor and then that athlete can
say however much money you think you'd
lose from me posting this image you're
going to lose tfold when I include you
in my complaint I make more than enough
money with my other sponsors I don't
need you anymore so I've been telling
pro skateboard companies this and
they're they're they're salivating why
many of these guys in Pro skateboarding
hate wokeness they're Rebels they want
to push security guards and do stupid
garbage I tell them not to do that by
the way and they're walking on eggshells
but they're scared they'll get attacked
and I said don't worry we're going to
flood the Zone we're going to build
media and we are going to be the the the
tip of the spear on this one and then
once we pay the way you can say don't
look at me but the money will be there
that's the point of building culture
then the young people who are growing up
are going to see Fearless Freedom punk
rock Etc we can say what we want you
can't shut us up and that's how we push
back on the W garbage thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at
timcast.net next
time